de lo que quiero hablar ahora es de las
formas de las distribuciones y las
palabras que usamos para describir las
aquí estamos hablando del café de memo y
dividimos a los clientes en varias
clases de acuerdo a su edad aquí están
las distintas clases de edad de 20 años
a 30 años de 30 años a 40 años y por
aquí tenemos el número de clientes del
café de memo que caen dentro de cada una
de esas clases porque esto aquí nos dice
que no hay ni un solo cliente que tengan
menos de 20 años y hay aproximadamente
25 clientes que tienen entre 20 y 30
años un poco más de 35 clientes que
tienen entre 30 y 40 años y después
conforme vamos aumentando la edad va
disminuyendo el número de clientes que
tienen esa edad y cuando tenemos una
distribución como ésta tal vez te salta
a la mente no sé por ejemplo un
armadillo
este es el cuerpo del armadillo y luego
por aquí tenemos lo que sería como la
cola del armadillo y la verdad es que si
usamos este tipo de términos para
referirnos a la forma de las
distribuciones lo que hay por ejemplo
esta tiene una cola hacia la derecha y
bueno no tiene una cola hacia la
izquierda porque no tenemos ni un solo
cliente menor de 20 años pero de este
lado que tenemos esta cantidad de
clientes entre 50 y 60 años pero después
entre 60 y 70 años tenemos una menor
cantidad y entre 70 y 80 tenemos todavía
menos clientes y luego otra vez un poco
menos de clientes a este tipo de forma
que puede tener una distribución le
llamamos cola y bueno está del lado
derecho por lo que decimos que la
distribución tiene una cola hacia la
derecha y estoy utilizando los
ejercicios de la página de khan academy
porque es una muy buena forma de ver
muchas distribuciones y tú también
deberías de usarlos porque ponen a
prueba
cimiento y así vas a aprender mucho más
y esta distribución no tiene una cola
hacia la izquierda porque aquí no
tenemos ninguna cola lo podemos ver aquí
no tenemos ninguna cola y además si
tuviéramos una cola entonces tal vez la
distribución sería aproximadamente
simétrica y recuerda para determinar si
algo es simétrico o no bueno hay varios
tipos de simetría pero el que podríamos
tener aquí defines un eje de simetría y
a los dos lados de ese eje deberíamos de
tener algo que funcionará como un espejo
aunque si dobláramos esta distribución
en el eje y pegaremos digamos esta parte
por aquí los dos lados deberían de
coincidir para que ésta tuviera una
forma simétrica pero eso no sucede aquí
porque cuando doblamos esta distribución
por aquí estas cuatro barras quedarían
por aquí pero este lado no tiene ni una
sola barra por acá entonces esta no es
una distribución simétrica
si es que solo tenemos que escoger esta
opción
y comprobamos la respuesta
tenemos aquí la edad de jubilación de
los huéspedes en el asilo san josé
tenemos aquí un montón de clases en esta
historia ma y aquí el número de
huéspedes que se jubilaron en estas
edades aunque entonces tenemos muchas
personas que se jubilaron entre 60 y 70
años y bueno en general esta
distribución se ve bastante simétrica no
podríamos poner un eje de simetría justo
a la mitad de esta clase digamos que el
eje estaría justo a la edad de 65 años y
si doblaremos esta distribución veríamos
que si son más o menos simétricas no
está barra no concuerda por completo con
esta otra barra pero si tienen una
altura muy parecida y lo mismo pasa con
estas otras barras aunque no tienen
exactamente la misma altura pero si
concuerdan más o menos entonces
decidiría que esta distribución es
aproximadamente simétrica
por aquí tenemos unas palabras muy
importantes el sesgo tiene una
definición muy técnica en estadística
que vas a ver más adelante pero viéndolo
de una forma más intuitiva e informal
generalmente cuando tienes únicamente
una cola hacia la izquierda está sesgado
hacia la izquierda y si tuvieras
únicamente una cola hacia la derecha
entonces estaría sesgado hacia la
derecha otra forma de pensar en que una
distribución esté sesgada hacia la
izquierda es si tu media está a la
izquierda de tu mediana en modo claro
que eso podría sonar demasiado extraño
para ti y te puedes quedar con la noción
de que si solo tiene una cola hacia la
derecha entonces está sesgada hacia la
derecha y si solo tiene una cola hacia
la izquierda o tiene una cola mucho más
larga hacia la izquierda entonces está
sesgada hacia la izquierda pero bueno
esta distribución es aproximadamente
simétrica comprobamos la respuesta
veamos otro ejemplo y nos toca uno muy
interesante porque no es un listo grama
no es una gráfica de barras aquí lo que
tenemos es una gráfica de caja y bigotes
que en realidad lo único que nos está
diciendo es dónde están los cuatro
cuarteles y recordando lo que sabemos
este punto de aquí es el mínimo de
nuestra base de datos es el punto
inferior de nuestro rango entonces por
lo menos tenemos un 11 podríamos tener
más y por aquí este punto es el máximo
lo que ahí tenemos un 25 y esta raya de
aquí es la mediana el valor de en medio
es 21 y luego la caja define el 50 por
ciento en medio de nuestros datos aunque
ella es algo así como la carne de una
hamburguesa es la parte de en medio de
nuestra distribución y si nos hubieran
dado un historial en lugar de una
gráfica de caja con bigotes tal vez y no
sabemos por qué aquí únicamente tenemos
los cuartiles
así es que aquí podríamos tener muchos
onces
no tantos como para jalar la caja hacia
la izquierda pero tal vez si están
distribuidos estos datos tal vez
tendríamos algo así como una cola y
luego por aquí sube la montaña y aquí
tiene más densidad ok y tendríamos aquí
una cola hacia la izquierda y no lo
puedo dibujar porque estoy en los
ejercicios de khan academy pero el hecho
de que este bigote sea muy largo nos
dice que aquí tenemos pocos valores o
sea que tenemos una especie de cola
blanca y este es el extremo del rango y
la distribución no es simétrica porque
si fuera simétrica la mediana estaría
justo en medio y esta caja estaría
también en el centro y sería simétrica y
tampoco está sesgada a la derecha porque
para estar sesgada a la derecha este
bigote tendría que ser larguísimo más
largo que el bigote de la izquierda
entonces la distribución está sesgada a
la izquierda lo que hay porque tiene una
cola hacia la izquierda
comprobamos la respuesta